la comisión de salud pública de españa
ha aprobado la vacunación contra la
viruela del mono una decisión que ya
habían tomado países como eeuu canadá o
reino unido eso sí con las dosis
disponibles en el país que son sólo
doscientas sólo se podrán beneficiar
ahora mismo unas cien personas ya que la
vacuna se administra en dos pautas con
cuatro semanas de separación y aún no se
sabe cuándo estarán disponibles las
dosis adquiridas en conjunto con los
demás países de la unión europea por eso
los expertos han decidido por ahora solo
vacunar a las personas que hayan estado
en estrecho contacto con un positivo y
que tengan un alto riesgo de gravedad o
de exposición como son por ejemplo todos
los trabajadores sanitarios el contacto
además tendrá que haber sido en los
cuatro días previos para poder recibir
la inyección la limitación de dosis ha
hecho que las autoridades descarten que
se utilice como medida de prevención
pese a que españa que roza los 260 casos
confirmados es el segundo país no
endémico con más positivos después de
reyno
hay que recordar que la vacuna que se
administrará es la de la viruela humana
enfermedad que la oms se había declarado
erradicada en todo el mundo en 1980 ya
que actualmente no existe una vacuna
contra la viruela del mono